So I just want to back up a
couple because I think there's
still some confusion about what
a restriction enzyme is and
exactly what it does,
although I indicated,
a three prime hydroxyl and a
five-prime phosphate.
Let me show you.
This is the way a lot,
at least a large class of
restriction enzymes,
went.
We've seen a deoxyribose
backbone before with a phosphate
backbone going on up to the next
nucleotide.
This is the five-prime
position.
This is the three prime
There is a phosphate here.
It goes down to the next one.
It goes down like this.
So what I'm showing you,
GAATTC, five prime to three
prime, here's where I indicated
the first cut comes from.
And I indicated that the
cleavage generates a G with a
three prime hydroxyl,
and the G ends up with a five
prime phosphate.
So what that means is that the
hydrolysis happens right there,
so that after cleavage,
what you end up with is a
five-prime phosphate and three
prime hydroxyl.
This is paired with the C on
the opposite strand.
It makes one cut here,
and then it would make an
identical cut on the opposite
strand.
So if we were to pull those
apart this strand here would
have G with its three prime OH,
and the other strand would be
TTAA.
And if we were to pull the
apart.
We'd have A A T T C,
a three prime OH here,
five prime phosphate there,
five prime phosphate there.
Again, you have to remember,
this strand is going five
prime, three prime in that
direction.
This was going five prime,
three prime in the end.
And the beauty of these
restriction enzymes,
at least it's not true of all
of them.
But it's true of a lot of them
as they generate these what are
called sticky ends.
You can pull them apart.
They come back together,
though, and reform those base
pairs.
It's almost like having little
bits of Velcro at the end.
And when this end is looking
for a complementary sequence to
pair with.
It doesn't know what's out
here, and it doesn't know what's
out there, all it sees as this.
So I can cut this and rejoin it
or I can cut them and pull
apart, take another piece of DNA
that's been cut with the same
enzyme and therefore has the
same corresponding little sticky
ends on each end,
and it could insert right in
the middle.
And that's the principle of
cloning.
And it was the development of
these, if you will,
magic scissors that made it
possible to take this DNA which
looks so homogeneous,
nothing but GA's,
T's, and C's,
and then cut it up in defined
ways.
When I was a postdoc,
a friend of mine had just
purified $2 million worth of
EcoRI because he purified some
of this enzyme.
At that point,
the only way to get these
things was to produce them
yourself and purify them.
Now there are literally
hundreds of these and they
recognize different sequences,
and once people understood that
they existed,
then they just started to look
in different,
usually they're from bacteria,
and they just looked in
different bacteria until they
found another one.
And then they purified it.
So if you go to,
say, any of the companies that
do stuff for recombinant DNA,
you'll find lists like this.
Funny little abbreviations like
EcoRI usually have something
that tells you some abbreviation
related to the organism,
from which the restriction
enzyme was isolated.
And you can find things that
will cut, I won't say every
sequence, but very,
very, many sequences.
There are literally hundreds of
these, and you just order them.
And the next day,
a FedEx package arrives with a
little bit of the enzyme that
will cut at that sequence.
Another concept that seemed to
be a problem,
was what's a vector?
So if you understand that there
are sequence specific molecular
scissors, that if we have a
piece of DNA and there's an
EcoRI site here,
you would come to think of it
like that because it's going to
cut in a slightly skewed way.
Maybe there's another one right
here, another one over here.
If we take this DNA and cut it
with this particular enzyme,
we get a break here.
Then this will get this piece
running from here to here.
We'll get this little piece
here.
We'll get this piece here,
and will get whatever goes off
on those sides.
So that's naked DNA in a test
tube.
So I could cut any piece of DNA
at some sites generating a bunch
of fragments and if I just took
those fragments and transformed
them into E.
coli, I took naked DNA,
took it from the outside,
put it inside,
is it going to replicate?
No.
Why not?
Because there's a special
signal called the origin of
replication that says "start
replicating DNA here".
This came from a piece of
human, lets say some of my DNA,
it would not have a signal in
it that said to the E.
coli replication machinery,
"start replicating DNA right
here".
So the principle of,
apart from being able to cut
DNA fragments,
is you have together to
replicate so you can make lots
of lots of copies.
The trick is to attach the DNA,
at least a widely used trick is
to attach the DNA to something
that has an origin of
replication that will work in
the organism in question.
And that was what we call a
vector.
So this is an E.
coli cell.
Another thing that's very
confusing is all the circles
that show up in this course.
This is huge.
The vector was double-stranded
DNA that maybe,
let's say, had a unique EcoRI
restriction site in it.
That's the only EcoRI
restriction site.
The other thing that we'd need
to have is an origin of DNA
replication.
So, that's why this plasmid is
able to propagate itself.
This little circle of DNA is
able to propagate itself,
and then some kind of
selectable marker.
And, most of the time that's a
drug-resistance,
so although it doesn't have to
be.
And if we cut that here,
generate sticky ends,
then we can take this fragment
and stick it in here,
to give this piece here joined
to the vector.
And that's an insert.
Let's say it was that piece
there.
In fact, if you wanted to clone
DNA in E.
coli, and then have the plasmid
work in yeast,
if you just take that plasmid
that works, the vector with its
insert that works in E.
coli and put it in the yeast,
it won't replicate either.
And that's because these other
languages other than the genetic
code are not universal.
So, you also have to put also
in a sequence that said to the
yeast replication machinery
"start something here".
People call that a shuttle
vector, something that will
replicate in E.
coli or replicate in yeast,
and the same principle applies
to other organisms
Okay, now probably the
trickiest thing,
the thing where I sort of
muddled it on Friday,
and I apologize for that,
was this discovery of
restriction enzymes.
And again, some of you were
frustrated.
You said, why do I waste time?
Why not just tell you stuff
that's on the exam?
Okay again, people were talking
about molecular scissors when I
was an undergrad and grad
student, and chemists were
trying to think if they could
come up with some way to get
some specificity in how to
cutting DNA.
And the answer,
the discovery of restriction
enzymes didn't come from that
kind of experiment.
It came from somebody trying to
understand what seemed to be a
really obscure piece of biology.
Julie made up a lovely little
slide.
But I think it basically did
was I left at one of the little
layers that I usually show.
So, let me just talk.
Here's, again,
what Luria saw when he was
doing these experiments.
So, I'm going to tell you now
what was in strain A and B,
and maybe that will help.
But I wanted you first to see
it without knowing what anything
beyond what Luria knew.
OK, strain A has no restriction
enzyme, and no modification
enzyme.
And although there are
different types of modification
enzymes, many of them are
methylases.
So, we'll call that.
And this one has a restriction
enzyme.
And, it has corresponding
methylase.
Just to review that again,
if you can figure this pretty
much out from first principles
that if you were an organism,
and you had a restriction
enzyme that would cut this,
there are two things you can
possibly do to keep from cutting
up your own DNA.
One is to never have that
sequence of pure DNA.
That would prevent you from
cutting up your own DNA,
even though it has it.
It's pretty constraining now,
because somewhere in a
particular protein,
you might need that little bit
of sequence to encode something
that you need to make a critical
protein.
So instead what you find is
organisms have a restriction
enzyme, have those sequences,
but they don't cut up their own
DNA because they modify their
own DNA, by putting,
in the case of this one,
they put a methyl here.
And I drew that out the other
day.
You can see,
you can put a methyl group on
the exocyclic amino group of
adanine, and not interfere with
base pairing.
But what you can do,
is interfere with the way that
the restriction enzymes sees
that sequence.
And when the cell pulls the DNA
apart, each of the old strands
is methylated,
and a new strand is initially
not methylated.
But that's enough keep the
restriction enzyme from doing
its thing.
And then the methylase will
come along, find a sequence,
and then the progeny strand,
the daughter strand,
will begin to get methylated.
So, once you get DNA
methylated, you can propagate it
as long as you have the methyl
group.
So this was what was really
underlying what Luria did.
But he didn't know that.
Let me quickly just go through
this again.
So he grew the strain,
the phage on strain A,
no restriction enzyme,
just plain old DNA.
So, he picks a plaque that's
probably about a billion phage
in a plaque, somewhere around
10^8, 10^9 probably,
no that's not true,
a little less than that,
somewhat less than that,
but lots and lots of phage
particles in the plaque.
Resuspend them and then plate
them out.
And of course it grew on strain
A.
That's what it was growing on.
That wouldn't surprise you at
all.
The surprise was,
even though he knew he had lots
and lots of phage,
hardly any of them grew on
strain B.
But, he found a rare plaque
that had learned to grow.
And he tested then,
and this thing grows on strain
B.
That was not a surprise because
it had to grow on strain B to be
up there.
And he tested,
and it still grew on the strain
A.
So up until now,
everything we knew,
everything we've talked about
in that course,
you think, ah-ha,
this original phage couldn't
grow on strain B,
but it's mutated.
Somehow.
It's learned to grow on strain
B.
That would be a perfectly
reasonable explanation.
But if that were the case,
what would've happened?
Well it was growing on those
phage, you pick them again,
it should still grow on A and
B, and they still do.
The problem with that model was
that they grew on strain A.
They had trouble growing on
strain B.
Now that we've learned to grow
on strain B, but you hadn't
forgotten how to grow on strain
A.
But if you take the ones that
were growing on strain A,
they grow on strain A,
not a surprise.
This is the problem right here.
If this was a mutant,
permanent change,
then we should have been able
to have it grow on strain B as
well.
So what was really happening in
there?
Well, at the beginning,
the phage DNA was lacking any
kind of modification.
It grew fine on strain A,
because there was no
restriction enzyme.
When it went into strain B,
that now had an enzyme,
a restriction enzyme that cut
up any time it found that
sequence.
And so, most of the phage that
injected their DNA,
those DNAs were trashed by the
restriction enzyme.
But there is a methylase in
there that's also able to
methylate those sequences.
And what happened somewhere
along the way was that there was
the methyl, on one phage DNA,
and got enough methyls on there
that the phage could be
replicated before it got cut up
by the restriction enzyme.
Once the phage molecule has
methylations on the site,
it's able to grow just fine on
strain B, and it will be able to
do that forever.
However, if you take that DNA
with the methyls on it,
and we put it back strain A,
it'll still grow,
as this one doesn't have any
kind of restriction enzyme,
but while it's growing its busy
losing all the methyls again.
We are right back to where we
started from.
An obscure experiment,
one of the most obscure you
could get, many people would
have paid no attention.
It does not seem worth it.
So, the phenomenon was called
restriction.
They had to give it a name.
It wasn't mutation.
They said this phage DNA was
being restricted somehow when it
grew on strain B.
People called them,
postulated there must be a
restriction enzyme that was
doing this restricting of phage
growth.
When they found out what was
doing it, they had discovered
magic scissors that would cut
DNA at particular sequences.
So, the point here again,
to try and go back and do this,
I hope some of you will get
this anyway, many of the really
important discoveries come out
of basic research.
They are easy to ridicule.
Why would I spend money on
cancer, human disease or
something, for somebody studying
some little weird phenomenon
about phage.
But if you want to trace back
to the experiment,
it sort of started the biotech
industry.
It was the discovery of
restriction enzymes.
It took a little while to
discover what it was,
but the reason they were
discovered, were people were
trying to understand that
phenomenology.
Once we got restriction
enzymes, we already had ligase,
which is sort of the tape we'd
need, and just to show you here,
when we go back to this one,
you can see that if we put
these together again,
we have a three prime hydroxyl,
and a five-prime phosphate.
That's what DNA ligase knows
how to do, because that's how
you seal up the end of a Okazaki
fragment.
So, that particular part of the
molecular biology toolkit was
already known to molecular
biologists who had been studying
DNA replication.
OK, so, if we took some DNA
from anything,
and we cut up into pieces like
this, and then we join them with
a vector that had been cut,
so let's just sort of open it
up a little bit,
this fragment would go in here
into one vector molecule.
This fragment would insert in
another vector molecule,
and so on and so forth.
Then we would have what I said
was a library,
and the problem at this point
is, so you transform those into
E.
coli, and now we have a whole
series of E.
coli.
They have their own chromosome,
every one of them because they
still have to be a bacterium.
So, let's take three members of
E.
coli from this library,
and they will all have this
vector, but they'll have,
let's say, insert number 1,
2, 3.
This insert is a little.
This insert is bigger,
and so on.
If we did it right.
We have every possible fragment
of DNA from the original source
sitting in its own vector.
And the whole collection of E.
coli in this population in the
certain library,
and the next part of the trick
was, how do you find the thing
you want, especially if you take
my DNA with 3 billion base
pairs.
That's an awful lot of
restriction fragments no matter
what you do.
How do you go about doing it?
So the experiment that I showed
you at the end of the lecture,
cloning by complementation,
is fairly simple,
and it was basically one of the
first methods that was used to
find genes in recombinant
library.
And that would be,
for example,
something that had thisGene
mutation in the chromosomal DNA.
This is what the situation I'd
described the other day.
So, if we put the library into
every cell, such that the
bacterium we transformed the
library into was broken for the
hisG gene, and that mutant
couldn't grow on minimal medium
unless we put in added
histadine.
But, if one member of that
library had the wild type,
hisG gene, let's say it was
this one here,
maybe it had several genes on
it.
But let's say over here.
We had hisG+,
then the strain is back to
being able to synthesize
histidine because it's got all
the enzymes.
What I was pointing out was
this really is complementation,
just like we did in that phage
cross.
We've got one broken copy of
the gene.
We've got a good copy.
And all you need is one good
copy, and you're back in
business.
What I was saying at the end of
the lecture was this is not a
general solution,
though.
If I wanted to find the
corresponding histidine gene
from my DNA, and all of these
biosynthetic pathways,
pretty much they rose so early
in evolution,
the biochemistry is essentially
identical in all cells.
Can I use this approach to find
the same gene for my DNA?
What do you think?
Why don't you turn to somebody
beside you and see if you can
talk for a minute,
and then let's see if,
I can think of at least a
couple of problems.
Let's see if you can come up
with one or two of them.
Find somebody near you and see
if you can come up with
anything.
00:22:23<clear/>
Anybody want to volunteer?
An idea of why it would not
work?
Or some of you think it would?
No ideas?
God, it's Monday.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel like most of you guys.
Somebody, come on.
What do you think?
It's going to work?
No idea?
What has to happen for it to
work?
I'll give you a vector that has
my gene corresponding to that
enzyme.
It's in E.
coli.
I need to make the protein.
Yeah?
No, it's in the vector.
We cloned it into an E.
coli vector.
So, that's got it.
Yeah?
Well it'll have a language that
will say "start transcription",
but whose language is it going
to have?
It's going to have my
transcriptional stuff.
Will that work in E.
coli?
Even though the open reading
frame is fine,
that's good.
How about translation?
I didn't even tell you about
that.
There is actually some specific
stuff needed.
That's not universal,
either.
So when you get the RNA you
still have to translate it.
There is another thing that
might mess us up.
Do you remember anything else
about, yeah?
Introns and exons?
What if my gene has introns in
it, which it almost surely has?
We have to get rid of those.
E.
coli doesn't know what they
are.
It's not used to taking them
out.
You see the issues?
Although that's a cute thing
and that helps you find a gene
from E.
coli by complementing E.
coli mutant,
or maybe you could do it with
yeast if you had a factor that
would replicate in yeast,
it wasn't a general solution.
So people had to use a whole
variety of different ways.
Here's another way.
You know that you have that
genetic code.
That was worked out years ago.
So let's say I was a
biochemist, and I'd found a
protein that I was interested
in, and I purified it,
and they got it out to single
protein, and then I could cut it
up with things that proteases
that will cut the protein into
pieces, and there are ways of
sequencing protein.
I'm not going to tell you how
it works in this course.
We just don't have time.
But you can get the sequence of
little pieces of protein.
And let's imagine that this was
the sequence of part of the
protein that I purified.
It's one of my enzymes [SOUND
OFF/THEN ON]
and I'd like to find the gene.
Well, how could I use that
information to figure out where
the gene is in this library?
So here's the strategy.
We get out the genetic code,
which Gobind Khorana and
Marshall Nirenberg helped work
out, and we say OK,
alanine, and if you look it up,
what you'll find is that it's
GC, and then it can be A T C or
G.
It can be any of those.
If we look up what the codon
for aspartate.
We'll find that there's a G or
an A, but it could be T,
or it could be C.
We look up lysine;
it'll mostly be A,
but it could be A or G.
You'll notice the variation of
those things is almost all in
the third codon if that hadn't
struck you.
Same thing with threonine:
A, C, and this is another one;
therefore codons that encode
this.
And this one asparagine is
that.
So knowing that piece of the
protein doesn't define a unique
sequence.
Though, what we could do it is
we could synthesize what's
called a mixed probe.
And that would mean when we are
going to synthesize this DNA and
we'd start with a G building
block.
And then we'd add a C building
So, now we made G and C.
And at the next step,
we'd add an equal mixture of A,
T, G, and C.
So, what we would get out of
that would be we'd be getting G,
and then the next biosynthetic
step would give us G,
C.
And then the next biochemical
step would give us GCA,
GCT, GCC, or GCG.
At the next step,
we'd add a G.
So everyone of these would get
a G.
Everyone would get an A,
and then the next step,
they would branch.
And if you follow that out,
you'll see by the end you have
a mixture of probes.
One of them is going to be the
right one that you find in the
DNA.
Now if you work out the number
of possibilities,
you'll discover that most of
the time there is only going to
be one probe that's unique.
Once you get to about 20
nucleotides, any sequence,
on average, is represented once
in the human genome.
So as long as you make the
probe long enough,
one of the things in your
mixture will be a defined probe.
So, what we can take is we have
all these different pieces of
DNA that are the logical
variants you can see here.
And then we would label the
probe with P32.
It's a radioactive isotope,
and it's very easy.
You can add it to a five-prime
phosphate.
There's a special enzyme that
will very easily take the
terminal phosphate from ATP and
put it over.
It doesn't really [SOUND
OFF/THEN ON]
for this course how we get it
there.
But we can do is radioactively
label the probe.
So now we've got this mixture.
And, somewhere in this library
is a piece of DNA that's going
to have the gene that's encoding
the protein that we're
interested in.
So, how do you go about trying
to deal with that?
So, what we'll do is we'll
plate our E.
coli library onto a bunch of
Petri plates.
So, I won't put too many
colonies on here,
so we can sort of see a
pattern.
But, we'd have probably a lot
of them, and we'd have a bunch
of plates.
You can work out statistically
how many plates you have to have
to have a chance of finding your
gene of interest.
Then what we do,
is lay a membrane on the plate.
It's a particular type of
membrane, and what that will do
is it will make a copy of
everything that's there,
and we're going to save the
plate.
And then we're going to treat
the membrane,
OK?
We've got a membrane that's got
an identical pattern.
They've got some of the
bacteria from the colonies stuck
at the corresponding parts on
the membrane.
We're going to lyse the E.
coli; that means break them
open so all their insides spill
out.
We will denature the DNA by
treating with a condition.
You can, for example,
vary the pH and make the
strands come apart.
That gives single stranded DNA,
"ss" I'm using as an
abbreviation for single strand
of the strands you pulled apart.
And, this sticks to the
membrane.
So, now we've got,
at every one of these little
positions on the membrane
something that looks like this.
Here's the membrane,
and there's some sort of single
stranded DNA that's stuck to the
membrane in that fashion.
The DNA that's stuck here came
from the bacterium here that had
a particular insert.
Over here, we have all the E.
coli DNA and the vector DNA,
but we will have a different
piece of DNA in the vector.
Everybody with me?
OK, so if we were now to take
our radioactive probe that we
made up there and get the
conditions just right,
that single stranded probe will
come in, and it will try and
find its complement.
It'll form hydrogen bonds
because that's the lowest energy
well.
And, we think about it
thermodynamically.
And, if we can get it right,
the temperature and the
conditions right,
nothing will stick unless it's
an exact match to the sequence.
And, if we get the right probe
that can form hydrogen bonds
with everything on here,
and it's got P32 at this point,
what will happen is we'll have
now, the probe will stick,
say, to this particular colony,
now with radioactivity right
there.
So, put some photographic film
over the membrane,
and right here there's P32,
and that'll expose the film and
nowhere else.
And then, when we develop,
what we'll find is one,
if this works well,
anyway, one spot.
So, now we know that that
piece, that colony had a piece
of human DNA in it that was
related to the sequence from the
protein that I had purified.
So we go back to this colony,
I think our things have
probably migrated around a
little bit here.
Let's move this up just a
little bit, and make it a little
better.
So this one is this one.
So, now I can go back to this
colony and pick it out.
And, let's say it's this
insert.
So, now I've found I can
sequence the rest of that piece
of DNA.
We'll talk about how we
sequence DNA in the next
lecture.
So that's an alternative way of
identifying a clone of interest.
There was a particularly
painful way of finding a gene in
a library that we for the most
part do not have to do any more.
It was called positional
cloning.
And for example the gene that
when it's broken causes cystic
fibrosis, it's a very difficult
disease.
Humans who have cystic
fibrosis have a very tough time.
So there's a great deal of
interest in finding the gene
that was broken in these
patients.
Human geneticists,
I showed you something about
pedigrees, they would have a
chromosome.
They might have banding
patterns, and they would have
figured out that somewhere along
the chromosome that the gene for
cystic fibrosis lay somewhere
between two genetic markers that
they had identified.
Now, the amount of DNA between
something that you knew that the
gene was here,
and something knew that the
gene was there,
could be huge.
It could be many,
many, many times the size of
the E.
coli chromosome.
So, what people would do is
they'd clone something from
here, a little piece of DNA from
there, and also clone something
and they get a little piece of
DNA from there.
And then they go into the
library, and they try and find
something that had this DNA and
something that extended in this
direction the little bit.
By the sort of thing you'd have
marker A somewhere in the middle
of the cystic fibrosis gene but
you didn't know exactly where.
You'd clone a little piece of
DNA and use that to find another
one that overlapped with it.
And that you'd find,
use that to find another piece
of DNA.
You'd walk your way over this
way, and you'd start the same
process at the other end.
And, every one of these things,
the same kind of operation that
we've got here,
so cycles, and cycles,
and cycles of acquiring the
next adjacent piece of DNA,
and working your way along
here.
And you had to use more than
one different restriction
enzymes, otherwise you wouldn't
be able to get these overlaps.
And by doing that,
eventually they were able to
get all the DNA that was between
these markers.
They knew the cystic fibrosis
gene was there from the maps
they had made by studying human
pedigrees.
And then, once you knew the
sequence, then you'd take
candidate genes,
and you'd take a bunch of
cystic fibrosis patients,
and you'd start to see if every
person who had cystic fibrosis
had a mutation in that gene.
And, eventually they got it.
That process in the case of
cystic fibrosis took five years
to do that with a huge team of
people.
And, I guess it was from
1985-1990.
If you wanted to do that
experiment today.
We come now to one of the most
widely used ways to finding a
gene of interest,
and that is you go to the
computer.
The whole human genome sequence
is in there.
If we were to do that
experiment today,
we'd say, well,
I know what this gene is,
so you look that gene up in the
database.
And you knew what this gene was
and you look up the database.
Then you just look at all the
DNA that's in the middle.
And you'd see a whole series of
open reading frames.
And you'd probably say,
well, what do I know about the
biology of cystic fibrosis?
Could I make a guess?
Is it a membrane protein?
Is it not a membrane protein?
And, there are certain
characteristics that would
probably allow you to make a
guess.
And then, you could jump right
in and start sequencing DNA.
You could start the experiment
practically that afternoon
instead of five years later.
So, if you look back from the
literature, you'll find some of
the key genes;
in fact, in human biology,
we're isolated by this very
painful process of positional
cloning, and you hardly ever
have to do that now.
It may be the odd case where
something's needed,
but most of the stuff now,
there are these amazing
databases, and I'll give you the
URL for it at the beginning of
next lecture.
And I'll show you when,
this is an experiment in which
someone took this gene for
cystic fibrosis.
It is a membrane protein,
and it's one of those proteins
that mediates the passage of
chloride ions across the
membrane.
And, if that gets broken,
you end up with cystic
fibrosis.
What someone has done here is
they've taken that green
fluorescent protein gene.
And, they've fused it to the
end of the cystic fibrosis gene.
So, you can tell where the
cystic fibrosis gene is
localized in a lung cell by
looking to see where the
fluorescence is.
And, I think you can see that
the fluorescence is out there
along the membrane.
OK, so at the beginning of next
lecture, I'll introduce you to
how we take one of these
recombinant plasmids,
and make what's called a
restriction map.
It's using a very simple,
little piece of apparatus like
that, and we'll go in and tell
you about DNA sequencing,
and this PCR technique you've
heard, preliminary chain
reaction that you've heard so
much about, OK?